remember that the best way to support
the david pakman show
podcast youtube channel radio show
tv show satellite tv show twitch channel
live streams and everything else is to
become a member
at joinpacman.com it's quick it's easy
it feels good you can get the bonus show
every single day
and you can use the coupon code 2020 now
to save
66 off of the cost of a membership
consider it i'm inviting you go to
joinpakman.com
we are going to go to the phone lines at
617-830-4750 and see what is on the
minds of our viewers and listeners
starting today with our caller from the
623 area code who's calling today from
623
uh hello yeah that's you
hi uh this is ricky from phoenix ricky
what's going on
hi um so i have two questions to ask you
first would be about
q anon and um i'm getting people to
actually deconvert from the conspiracy
theory
by your interviews really like which i
mean i did one interview about it but
it's not a topic i've talked about too
much but that's helping people
yeah yeah so um a lot of people on
on my facebook i've been posting about
you know like q a and stuff and all that
so
and you know they've been blaming joe
biden for some whatever reason
saying that he's a beautiful or whatever
so i have been
you well i showed a video uh to people
about your
about your interview and then it's kind
of like
deconverting him from believing into
that kind of stuff that's good you know
what i'm saying
yeah that's great news if that's the
case i like them
yeah yeah it's because um a lot of
people don't want to vote for joe biden
because of the conspiracy theory so i'll
say
who knows if that's real or not but
let's face it this did come from a white
a right-wing group so who knows if it's
true or not
and you know i don't want you know since
we're in an election where like
it could go bad or it can go good who
knows um
yeah i'm just trying to like you know
deconvert people from thinking now so we
can actually get people to vote for
biden so we can at least like you know
hold the ball and you know go more left
from there you know what i'm saying
i i completely know what you're saying
and i think you're doing exactly the
right thing now at arizona interestingly
it's not looking so good for donald
trump right now
yeah um yeah also um i have been getting
people trying to vote for mark kelly as
well trying to get it blue so we can you
know
get martha mcsally so hopefully it does
go blue for us in the senate
it would be amazing i think you know my
sense is if arizona does go blue
i think it's not going to be a good
night for donald trump nationally i
think it's not just going to be arizona
if it goes bad for trump
yeah yeah i i yeah i hope i hope you
know trump gets out of office but i'm
using your videos to actually you know
get people to vote for biden you know
like
if i see your videos on facebook i'll
share it if
i see anything that could actually
benefit people to like know more about
buying like
why it would be beneficial for people
i'll share your video maybe that's why
you're getting
you know 1 million subscribers you know
what i'm saying ricky i think you were
responsible for us getting to a million
subscribers absolutely i think you are
uh
you are overwhelmingly the source of
that and i really appreciate it
oh yeah so yeah i'm just trying to make
sure you know people make a better
choice in terms of this election because
i don't want to like make well you know
what you get what i'm saying you know i
gotta hopefully hopefully we can
yeah but the second question is how can
what are other ways i can get people to
vote for biden
because i get there's people too far
gone
but there are people that are reluctant
to either vote or not vote
oh right yeah so so listen don't try to
argue with
i think arguing with trump supporters is
a much tougher thing to do
than just finding people who don't like
trump but who maybe
may not be planning to vote and explain
to them donald trump is going to claim
that it was rigged
we need every vote it's not enough for
joe biden to win by a hundred votes
he needs to win by a million or ideally
five million or ideally seven million or
whatever so
so if there's ever an election that
we need every vote for it's this one
because those extra votes are what could
be the difference between
trump credibly saying it was rigged and
trump not being believed when he says it
yeah no yeah i totally get you um yeah
um because i also bring about policy
like you know
uh biden wants to raise the minimum wage
to 15
that does catch a lot of people's eyes
in terms of voting for biting
so you know i do i do use that tactic
of just like you know raising the
minimum wage and just at least better
health care not
it's not the best but you know better
than nothing you know
i got you my friend all right ricky
great to hear from you you're doing
great work down there in arizona keep it
up okay
all right all right well thank you thank
you all right there's ricky from phoenix
doing doing it all doing it all